a Geneva 2 and Jonathan Lions became the
first American journalist allowed to
work in Iran since the nineteen
seventy-nine revolution the
husband-and-wife duo chronicled their
experiences and observations in the new
book answering only to God faith in
freedom in 21st century Iran they spoke
recently at the Carnegie Council in New
York City for about an hour good
afternoon good afternoon I'm Joanne
Myers director of Merrill house programs
and on behalf of the Carnegie console
I'd like to welcome our members and
guests and c-span book TV to our author
in the afternoon series today we are
very pleased to have with us Jonathan
Lions in Geneva abdo who will be
discussing their book answering only to
God this book will be available for you
to purchase at the end of the program
today due to the media's preoccupation
with the impending war in Iraq most
Americans were probably unaware that in
the same part of the world an
anniversary was taking place last month
it was reported that fewer radians took
to the streets to celebrate the 24th
anniversary of Ayatollah Khomeini
Islamic Revolution but for Iran watchers
this came as no surprise for the
revolutionary fervor that moved a nation
to sacrifice so much for so long seems
to have lost its momentum long ago when
Ayatollah Khomeini created the modern
world's only theocracy he promised a
heaven on earth in which the poor and
oppressed would rule and be free instead
the country has been plagued by
political paralysis corruption massive
unemployment social restrictions and
repression it now appears that this
theocracy has lost two of its most
powerful sources of control moral
authority and political legitimacy and
is ruling by coercion alone with a
constitution that stipulates both
religious and democratic rule it has
become quite clear that after 24
post-revolutionary years this government
can
happy satisfactory run both by the
elected representatives of the people
and the self-appointed unelected
representatives of God in answering only
to God our guest this afternoon two
veteran journalist tell the story of
this power struggle taking place between
those claiming to speak in the name of
Islamic purity and those who call
themselves Democrats as they stayed in
their book they went to Iran on a
mission little did they know however
that it would be one that would set them
on a collision course with the press the
authorities the secret police and the
rest of the Iranian establishment during
the three years in which they were based
in Iran they conducted hundreds of
interviews with leading theologians
dissidents hardliners and reformers
going where a few Westerners were ever
permitted to go before these discussions
form the basis of this engrossing
reportage on present-day Iran which
prompt them to raise the perennial
question of whether Iran is an Islamic
state ruled by clerics or a republic
ruled by the people many of you may
remember j'ni from her previous visit to
the Carnegie Council when she discussed
her book no god but God Egypt in the
triumph of Islam she may also be
familiar to you as a commentator on
islamic affairs as she has appeared
often on NPR PBS the BBC Jim Lehrer
Newshour CNN and this afternoon Oprah
from 1998 until 2001 she served as a
correspondent in Iran which reported for
the newspaper the guardian of London and
contributed articles to the economist
and the International Herald Tribune
most recently she was a Neiman fellow at
Harvard University and a guggenheim
fellow she was also the recipient of a
Ford Foundation grant for research on
Iran currently she is a correspondent
for the Boston Globe based in Washington
focusing on Middle East issues Jonathan
Lyons is a Washington editor for Reuters
news agency in 1998 he opened the
agency's bureau in Tehran 14 years after
it had been closed by Iranian
authorities mr. Lyons has covered turkey
the collapse of the Soviet Union and the
rise of the
dependent republic's he has been a
mid-career fellow at Columbia
University's Harriman Institute for
Advanced Study of the Soviet Union in
February 2001 both geneve and Jonathan
were expelled from Iran under threat
prosecution and have been banned from
returning since please join me in
welcoming our guests today Geneva and
Jonathan thank you for joining us I
believe that Jonathan is going to go
first yeah thank you very much for the
kind introduction thank you all for
coming out under trying conditions
answering only to God tells the story of
the national struggle now underway in
contemporary Iran it is a struggle set
in motion at the birth of the Islamic
Republic in 1979 between two
fundamentally different understandings
of the new state that arose from the
ashes of the us-backed monarchy
underlying the domestic turmoil which is
mostly visible and widely reported in
the Western press as the confrontation
between reformers and conservatives by
several basic questions these include
what is the true instrument of God's
will in an Islamic Republic does
ultimate authority reside with senior
theologians qualified to interpret the
holy law or is it the people as
expressions of God's genius who exercise
sovereignty in his name answering only
to God takes these questions as its
starting point and examines Iran at the
dawn of the 21st century through the
prism of this theological debate but as
Joanne mentioned answering only to God
is also our story that is the story of
the first American journalists in this
case husband and wife to live and work
in Iran since the aftermath of the
revolution we arrived in June 98 at a
time of great promise Iran which had
witnessed the creation of the first
theocracy of the modern age now seemed
ready to give birth to a new kind of
state one that made room for both
Islamic tradition and personal and
political freedom President Mohammed hot
to me was still in his first year of
office and change was in the air he been
elected in 1997 in a landslide on
promises to reduce the arbiter
power of the state and he pledged to
implement what he called the rule of law
and to create a civil society within
Iran's existing Islamic political system
he spoke eloquently of the need for
greater social and political pluralism
and he promised to break Iran out of its
international isolation chiefly through
what he called a dialogue of
civilizations on a more prosaic level
the Iranian of the American soccer teams
were about to meet in Paris in the world
cup and what many saw as a harbinger of
improved relations with the Great Satan
in the streets of Tehran this recalled
Nixon's ping-pong diplomacy which opened
the way to relations with the People's
Republic of China for our party and even
I found ourselves drawn to Iran after a
number of years working in Egypt Turkey
and many other Muslim countries as
Joanne mentioned Geneva presented her
earlier book no god but God Egypt in the
triumph of Islam in this very room in
october two thousand that study
documented for the first time the
transformation of Egypt into an Islamic
society the results of a grassroot the
grassroots movement from the bottom up
by contrast answering only to God
portrays Iran's transformation from the
top down as imposed by the clerical
regime president ought to me like
Islamic reformers throughout history
argues that the needs of modern Muslims
could be met if reason and rationality
were only introduced into the practice
of the faith his ideas energized much of
the Muslim world at the time Muslims
yearning for greater freedom of
expression expanded religious and
political tolerance and increased
participation of women and minorities
the promised land of the modern islamic
movement the founding of a true islamic
republic at last appeared within reach
so geneve and i packed up our house in
istanbul and fluted tehran however we
soon found ourselves chronicling the
failure of the hot to me experiments a
decline in fortune that mirrored our own
at the hands of the Iranian authorities
welcomed with open arms in 1998 by the
hitomi loyalists in charge of the
Ministry of Culture we were later forced
to flee under threat of criminal
prosecution by these very same
reformists
now tensions with the government had
been building for some time largely over
the content / of our reporting and the
scope of our sources officials were
nervous about our extensive contacts
among the theologians in the holy city
of home in Geneva we'll talk about this
in a minute and they were increasingly
displeased with articles that catalogued
further no hitomi setbacks in particular
one piece that demonstrated that the
current Supreme clerical leader
Ayatollah Ali Khamenei wielded more
overt political power than Ayatollah
Khomeini before him the secret police
began to lean heavily on our researchers
our translators and our drivers the
press authorities vowed to take away our
visas and at least one Iranian newspaper
called Geneva spy and demanded her
expulsion so on Christmas Day 2000
archived in the backyard bonfire after
having discreetly carried copies of our
interview notes are recordings and other
documents to the west in our hand
luggage whenever we flew out of the
country for a holiday five weeks later
we slipped out of Tehran for good and
have been banned for returning as Joanna
mentioned finally answering only to God
is a cautionary tale one that is sorely
needed as America stands on the eve of a
war that many in power tell us is
designed not only to remove Saddam
Hussein from power but to refashion the
Middle East the Muslim Middle East in
particular in our own image in its most
Parvati 9 form this project would
encourage the so-called democratization
project that is the creation of
american-style democracies among the
authoritarian states that dominate the
region however this approach makes no
real allowance for the enormous cultural
religious and social distinctions
between the Muslim world and the West
nor does it take into account the
extraordinary dynamism of the modern
islamic movement or the risk of a
backlash now in order to understand the
contemporary islamic world we must set
aside notions that the region's
religious revival is filled simply by
the failure of secular states by poverty
or by envy of Western economic and
military might or its lavish lifestyle
we must come to grips with the dynamics
of the theological debate that lies at
the heart of today's struggle and as
answering only to God shows this central
conflict is not one of a clash of
civilizations nor of islam vs the West
it is a clash of islam vs islam despite
its high drama and profound implications
this struggle has received relatively
little attention in the west and a
number of factors contribute to this
phenomenon in the first place Western
analysts journalists and policymakers
are generally suspicious of viewing
religion as a primary actor in
contemporary societies second it is
extremely difficult to gain access to
the clerical cast to the seminary to
their reading circles and study groups
that comprise the true battlefield of
ideas what's more to view the Islamic
world on its own terms and to listen to
its own voices requires an uncomfortable
reassessment of the West long held
notions of faith society freedom and the
notion of human rights now in America
faced the horrors of September 11th a
consensus quickly emerged that Islam had
declared war on the West talking heads
across the country posed the same
rhetorical question why do they hate us
scholar steeped an Orientalist theory
were the heroes of the day and for
decades they had argued that the
attributes of Western modernity
primarily its economic military and
technological power had become too much
of a threat to the Islamic world their
warnings of a violent Islamic response
one intended to even the score were
seemingly vindicated once the World
Trade Center was reduced to dust and one
side of the Pentagon was torn open by
the flying bombs of Osama bin Laden but
the violent Eddie's of militant Islam
that have now spread to our shores have
little to do with our American Way of
life or our political or social freedoms
the true cause is the search for an
Islamic utopia a process that began with
the death of the Prophet Muhammad and
one that continues unabated today in the
moss of Egypt Pakistan and Algeria in
the mountain hamlets of Afghanistan and
in the seminaries of Shiite Iran
it is this perennial pursuit that lies
at the heart of England's attack on the
United States his primary grievance
articulated for decades to varying
degrees by moderate Islamic militants
and activists alike concerns the
shortcomings of Arab leaders not the
values or lifestyle of the West when the
West intervenes in the Muslims pursuit
of Islamic purity and religious
salvation either by supporting the
repressive rulers deemed to be
illegitimate in religious terms or by
interfering directly in the domestic
politics of the Muslim world only then
does it to become the enemy now I'd like
to give the Florida geneve who will
speak about the shia clerics and the
students to groups that in large measure
hold the future of Iran in their hands
as Jonathan explained the the source of
the current struggle and Iran lies in
the theological debate this debate
emerged primarily when Ayatollah
Khomeini resurrected an old concept in
Shiite Islam and then gave it new
meaning that concept was called the
valley atif a key or direct clerical
rule before the islamic revolution a
collective of Shiite jurists made
decisions but home a knee declared that
ultimate religious authority should be
in the hands of a supreme leader in
other words absolute authority should be
in the hands of one fallible man this
meant that the collective nature of
religious authority and Shiite Islam in
Shiite Islam would be lost as would be
the clerics ability to interpret the
Islamic texts as they saw fit even if
their opinions contradicted those of the
supreme leader though many clerics of
the time were opposed to this decision
they went along with home a knee because
he was such a respected theologian and
such a charismatic political leader his
rare talents which combined charisma and
religious authority put him in a very
unique position of being almost immune
to criticism at least open criticism
within the clerical cast but when home a
knee died in 1989 the weakness of this
system he had put in place became
apparent
his successor the current supreme leader
ayatollah khamenei had neither home a
knees religious credentials as a learned
and respected theologian nor did he have
his charisma which would enable him to
wield the kind of power that homemad had
this began the current friction among
the clerics and sharply divided the
clerical cast into three distinct
categories traditionalists who believed
cleric should remain outside politics
reformers or modernists who believed the
supreme leader should not have absolute
powers over state matters and who are
now trying to carve out a formula for an
Islamic democracy and hardline political
clerics who now make up the regime the
hardline clerics derive much of their
power by aligning themselves with hominy
and by working through an intricate
network that links Iran's mosques its
prayer halls and its religious
foundations during the time that we
spent in Iran I made several trips to go
the Shiite center of learning and Iran
to meet some of the clerics and to try
to understand and absorb their ideas it
was very clear that carving out an
Islamic Republic would never be achieved
until the clerics could reach a
consensus on the scope and power they
would have within the state the clerics
are also grappling with how to apply
Islamic laws in ways to meet the modern
demands of a vast majority of Iranians
and these Iranians feel that their lives
now are burdened and bogged down by
religion one of the most interesting
clerics I met was a man named Wilson
Khedive our who actually this year is a
visiting scholar at Harvard University
mr. Khedive are comes from an
enlightened middle-class family and he
has devoted his adult life to trying to
create a formula for an Islamic state
which also allows for a Republican rule
and it is in this way that he believes
the Islamic Republic failed in its
mission when it since its creation in
1979 one of his central critiques of the
current system is that
clerics now must distinguish between
those rules in Islam which are eternal
and those which are relevant only to a
specific time and place in other words
in the divine state are its subject or
is it subject to in a divine state is it
subject to change depending upon the
will of the people caddy for favors
giving Iranians the right to determine
which Islamic precept should apply to
their lives in the modern world and it
is this theory which poses a great
threat to the Conservatives now running
the state the Conservatives feared that
relinquishing such power could
eventually make them obsolete if
ordinary Iranians are given the license
to define their relationship with God
what role then would that leave for the
clerics running the state Cathy VARs
ideas about the power of the Supreme
Leader also made him an enemy of the
hardliners running Iran in his numerous
books and articles he set out to prove
for example that there was no evidence
either derived in the Quran or the
collective sayings of the Prophet
Muhammad sanctioning the absolute power
of the Supreme Leader he pointed out
that in Shiite theology with its
traditional disdain for political life
there was no discussion of the proper
form of government and Islamic state
should have in the absence of the
infallible imams mr. Cannavaro maintains
that believers are in charge of managing
their own affairs and that ultimate
authority must come from God not from a
fallible human being caddy VARs views
are in direct conflict with one powerful
conservative cleric by the name of Allah
hosseinian who holds enormous power
within hardline clerical circles because
I was trying to meet some of these
hardliners I went and met hosseinian and
he was one of the few clerics who was
willing to meet me among those who are
hardliners many people cautioned that I
should not do this because hosseinian
was feared across Iran because he was
believed to be behind the murders of
secular intellectuals in the 1990s when
I met him however he was very surprising
in that he was nothing like the
cardboard figures and the stereotypes
that ax radians often described when
referring to the hardliners who ran the
regime he was very clever and pointed
out very important subjects that are
that are part of our discussion today he
first explained that the kind of
pluralistic system Iranians are striving
for would not resemble a western-style
democracy for the simple reason that
Western democracies do not have a role
for religion within the state instead he
said Iran was what he called a guided
Republic one that requires supervision
by the clerics so that it does not
deviate from an Islamic framework
hosseinian also rejected the idea of
permitting direct elections in Iran now
a body of clerics screens all candidates
who run in elections hosseinian
explained to me that the clerical
establishment should decide who would be
permitted to run in an election when I
pointed out to him that this was a Dem
undemocratic process he then reiterated
the point that western-style democracy
was not the goal of the Islamic Republic
so you can see from these two clerics
mr. Cadde d'ivoire and mr. Hosseini on
that the theological divide is very vast
which makes the struggle and Iran very
intense as the theological dispute has
developed another sector of Iranian
Society has also become involved in the
movement toward change university
students some of whom looked to clerics
such as Muslim k d'Ivoire and other
progressives for guidance have led this
movement for change students in Iran
historically have been critical to the
whole force of political change they
were very instrumental in the Islamic
Revolution in 1979 and their active
activism has been consistently a
barometer of society's hopes and dreams
University students worked hard to elect
President Hassan II in 1997
but since then many in the umbrella
student movement which is called the
dakhtar Hakeem buff dot have parted ways
with the president convinced that he
will never bring fundamental reform to
Iran they see him now for what he is a
cleric whose primary ambition is to
preserve the existing Islamic system the
turning point in hot Amy's relationship
with a student movement and in fact one
of the great turning points in the
reform movement occurred in the town of
hamadan in the summer of nineteen ninety
nine it was about ten days after student
demonstrations had had broken out across
the country these were the largest
demonstration since the after aftermath
of the Islamic Revolution the students
began their protest by demonstrating
against the closure of a reform
newspaper and the demonstrations lasted
six days in Hamadan two weeks after the
students had risked their lives in these
demonstrations they anxiously gathered
at in the town to hear what hot to me
had to say I remember standing in the
crowds of the young women men and women
and they were so excited to see the
president they tried to dismantle rows
of still barricades to move closer to
hot Sammy's podium many were actually
taken away in ambulances after they
passed out from the heat and the
excitement but instead when stealing
confidence in his foot soldiers fighting
in the street for change the president
betrayed them how to me did indeed
concede that an attack on the Tehran
University dormitories which had
prompted the student demonstrations was
a crime but he rewrote history that
followed the next days after the
demonstrations he said for example that
no shots were fired in these
demonstrations and Jonathan ly were
actually on the streets of Tehran during
these demonstrations and we saw the
Islamic militia and many vigilantes fire
at the students and spray tear gas in
the town of Tabriz where the worst
violence occurred the militia created
what they called a tunnel of death and
forced the student demonstrators
to pass through this gauntlet and beat
them along the way yet hot to me yet for
hot to me it was apparently more
important to deny that violence was
inflicted upon the students than it was
to defend the integrity of the system
the hardliners within law enforcement
agencies who had beaten the students
were backed by the conservative
establishment and hot samee was not
willing to confront the hardliners
within the regime hot to me told the
crowd in Hamadan my dear ones today in
order to put down riots and in order to
put out the flames of violence for the
nation others you tent use tanks armored
cars and heavy weapons our forces did
not use firearms to tackle the writing
the disturbance was put down calmly and
without resorting to firearms well of
course we knew that that wasn't true
having been witness to the witnesses to
these demonstrations the this incident
sealed hot amis fate and it led to what
is now a student movement led by
radicals who believed that the reform
movement has failed when discussing
students in Iran Westerners often ask
what does the next generation really
want the answer is complicated but it is
not what most people assume many student
leaders are not in favor of creating a
secular state and Iran instead they want
to establish a state structure which
allows for freedom and civil liberties
but also takes islamic values into
account this is the reason they consider
clerics such as muslim Khedive are among
their heroes after the student protests
in 1999 I went to search for some of
these radical students who then were
still fairly invisible and I met them in
a run-down apartment in downtown Tehran
as they set before me for several hours
and discussed their visions of the
future I asked them directly do you hope
that Iran will develop a western-style
democracy and they said no in fact they
pointed to the headline in the cover on
the cover of The Economist at the time
which read Iran's second revolution
referring to the protests that had just
occurred I had actually written the
Arctic
inside which did not make the claim that
the student protests were precursor to a
second revolution but that's how the
world interpreted the demonstrations and
as the students correctly pointed out to
me that was not their mission even in
the long term their mission was not to
create a second revolution in iran to
topple the clerics from that time
forward iran students have grown even
more radical during the protests which
occurred last december and last november
they openly chanted against supreme
leader ayatollah khamenei an act which
could land many student leaders in jail
the key question now of course is
whether the student movement can create
enough pressure within the system to
force change it depends greatly upon
whether the students in the coming years
can inspire other other sectors of
society to join them along this road
toward reform they cannot do it alone
and this is another misconception yet
there is internal yes there is internal
rebellion and Iran and there is
discontent but when President Bush and
other administration officials declare
openly that they support the Iranian
people which is effectively code
language for their support of an
internal rebellion which would topple
the regime they don't understand that
this movement is at a ver is in a very
early stage the students are leading the
way but it will take a broad-based
social movement to change the system in
the same way that it took Ayatollah
Khomeini at least three decades to bring
about the Islamic Revolution in 1979 the
recent local elections in Iran marked
the formal low point for the hot to me
movement in a capital Tehran which when
we were living there was a hotbed of
pro-reform activism only twelve percent
of eligible voters even bothered to cast
ballots and across Iran the candidates
aligned with hot to me fared poorly all
those supporting the conservative
factions gained strength the seeds of
this dismal result were sown as far back
as July 1999's Geneva's mentioned
particularly with the speech in Hamadan
on hot Timmy made it clear
that he would throw in his lot with the
establishment and over time we watch his
hot to me steadily abandoned the rest of
his core supporters that is the
religious intellectuals including many
prominent newspaper editors publishers
and commentators as well as
reform-minded clerics feminists and lay
activists in one particular poignant
moment two leading newspaper men that we
came to know quite well mashallah
shamsul visine and hamid reza jolly poor
sent a letter to a president whose
agenda they had been pushing
relentlessly in their newspapers asking
for his protection from the hardline
police and the courts now these were
brave men ready to risk prosecution for
their pro-reform convictions and jolly
pour a big gregarious figure even kept a
kit bag with a razor and toothbrush by
his desk waiting for the police to come
and haul him off and in fact both men
did time in jail yet they could not
disguise their hurt or their anger that
they'd been abandoned by the symbolic
head of the reform movement quote either
tell us that our press activities are
illegal they wrote or tell us clearly
from which government bhatti we are to
get a minimum of political and
professional security to continue our
work they had taken hot to me at his
word and pursued his reform to its
logical conclusions with the police
virtually knocking on their door they
asked where was the president now ought
to me never responded now at least four
factors contributed to the failure of
the hot to me movement first the
President as neva said was a product and
a loyal product of the system he sought
to reform second his commitment to an
understanding of the broader reform
project and its deep theological social
and political implications was always in
question third the obstacles to profound
structural change in particular those
posed by the Islamic Constitution that
all but guaranteed the hold of the
hardline clerics were enormous and
finally the president and his allies
failed to build a firm foundation for
their proposed Islamic civil society
they abandoned proposals for creating
genuine political parties and grassroots
organizations as too difficult and
time consuming and instead they relied
on a sort of media campaign in this case
the creation of an independent press to
carry the day on a cold winter day in
1997 mama taught to me presented himself
to the supreme leader Ayatollah Khomeini
he was considering a run for the
presidency but he had told his backers
he would first was determined to give
the leader who has the final say in all
matters of state a final veto on his
candidacy ha to me told the leader that
his message of tolerance pluralism and
openness could draw Iranians who had
grown increasingly apathetic and cynical
back into the political system he would
also reach out to women and ethnic
minorities broadening popular support
for the Islamic system and by extension
for the leader himself now the leader
like everyone else in Iran felt that hot
Smee had not a single chance of winning
and so he gave the candidate his
blessing but made no comment on his
election platform and the unintended
result as you will recall was the
landslide victory of Mahrt of May 1997
now it's also important to recognize
that the reforms that came to be
associated with Muhammad hot to me
represent only one of several key
strands that made up the coalition of
clerics workers leftist militias secular
and religious intellectuals Iranian
nationalists and university students who
carried out the Islamic Revolution two
decades before now for years any push
towards greater democracy was
subordinated to the demands of
consolidating the revolution and
purifying society of Western influence
it was also dedicated to the struggle
with the Great Satan in the aftermath of
the u.s. embassy takeover shortly
thereafter the bloody around Iraq war
which dragged on free years further
[ __ ] any steps towards reform and
was only with the end of the war and the
death of home a knee a man by the way
who's Sun Records was broken by his
failure to bring down Saddam Hussein
with the death of how meny the reformer
suddenly began to find their voice among
them was a young man named ali reza alla
vita bar an intellectual a radical act
and an early recruit to the
Revolutionary Guards which were created
to defend the new revolutionary regime
elevator bar volunteered for the front
at the outbreak of the war and he stayed
until the very bitter end watching his
comrades die or slowly filter back to
civilian life he stayed he told us in a
series of lengthy interviews in his
office long after he'd begun to doubt
the conduct of the war and prospects for
victory recuperating from wounds he
received in battle alla alla vita bar
recalled he cried uncontrollably as he
heard Iranian state radio announced the
armistice with Iraq but he and many of
his comrades also began to realize that
they had to change a system in whose
name they've been prepared to die quote
for a whole generation of activists and
thinkers the last years of the war made
them rethink things helping them to
accept reformist ideas we do not
criticize during the war not because we
were afraid but because we thought those
making the decisions back home were
infallible however the lack of victory
in the war raised questions in people's
minds close quote now alla vita bar and
his fellow travelers at the time were
still very much on the outside of
political power but they give a hand to
come together in interlocking discussion
groups and reading circles that linked a
government think tank a few modest
publishing houses the state news and
news agency erina and several government
agencies among those on the periphery
was the bookish cleric and former
minister of culture mohammad hatha me
together this band of intellectuals
debated the notions that were to form
the core of the future hot to me
campaign that is the rule of law civil
society and a dialogue of civilizations
the tensions within the hot to me
coalition began to show within days of
its stunning electoral victory activists
like shamsul visine and jolly poor the
man with the kit bag were impatient to
push the reformist agenda they argued
for the immediate creation of a
political party and the creation of
grassroots organizations but they were
vetoed by powerful rivals inside the hot
to me camp instead the two men joined by
instead the two men joined by the
us-educated engineer
senses gara for their enormous energies
into creating the first truly modern
newspapers of the post-revolutionary era
now this had turned out was a fateful
decision for hot to me himself a former
newspaper publisher and other
intellectuals the written word was a
seductive device and a free press they
argued would mobilize public opinion act
as a check on the state an energized
society beaten down by revolution war
death and suffering but the hardline
authorities soon recognized the danger
of the newspaper revolution the election
of hot to me was bad enough they
reasoned but the unbridled voice of a
truly independent press was another
matter altogether backed by the Supreme
Leader the Tehran prosecutor closed the
newspaper and the jail jailed its
founders so began a game of
cat-and-mouse between the pro-reform
press and the hardliners in control of
the courts religious imperative was
invoked to silence dissent and many
editors and publishers were jailed on
charges of violating Islamic values in
april two thousand these press wars
closed a dozens of newspapers prominent
editors and publishers were jailed or
prosecuted seven months later geneve and
i sat in the audience as president hot
to me confessed before a conference of
lawyers and jurists they had failed his
campaign promises to introduce the rule
of law and to create a society a civil
society had proven empty quote after
three and a half years a grim-faced
Hotham you said i must be clear the
president does not have enough rights to
carry out the heavy task on my shoulders
thank you
I'd like to open the Florida questions
and I have that you just waited until
the mic comes to you and identify
yourself and try to keep your question
breathe and point please thank you how
do you think the sudden new threat of a
couple hundred thousand American troops
on the Iranian border will affect the
internal debate that's going on right
now I mean there has been there's
already evidence that it has
strengthened the hardliners simply
because the rhetoric of the hardliners
for two decades has been against the
United States they've argued that the
United States is an imperialist power
that the United States wants to invade
the Middle East this has been part of
their strength really against any sort
of criticism you know I mean that their
position is if we seem unstable or
vulnerable the United States could come
and occupy Iran again and you know don't
forget there was a CIA back coup in Iran
in 1953 so there is some recent history
to this kind of anxiety so we've already
seen in the short term that the war in
Iraq has strengthened the position of
the hardliners now if of course the war
is successful if there's some sort of
democratic effort that succeeds in Iraq
that might change the dynamic the
political dynamic within Iran but you
know we don't know at this stage
my name is Peter Russell there are a
couple of bills before the majlis the
Parliament currently seeking to give the
President as I understand it more power
or to curb the power of the religious
authorities what do you see is the
prospects well I think the short answer
is not very good at least in the near
near term and in fact that's why in
answering only to God we focus so much
on the underlying religious struggle
because that struggle really has to be
resolved before political manifestations
such as new bills a new spelling out a
new sharing of power can really be put
into place so I'd say the near-term
prospects are not particularly good and
assuming that the tactics of the
Reformers haven't changed since we
interviewed them extensively in the
years that we were there i would say
they're counting on a defeat um i just
want to explain something in case you're
not aware of this even though there's a
there the Reformers comprise a majority
in the parliament there's something
called the Guardian Council which is a
body of clerics now they can veto
legislation and they do this regularly
so in a sense it makes the Parliament
more or less irrelevant mean that's the
problem
yeah kenwood worth Newsweek you Jonathan
used a phrase of the people as the
expression of God's genius is that a
traditional phrase and I asked it
because I'm wondering what what habits
what hobby just exists in Shiite Islam
and also in in the history of Iran on to
make us in any way confident that they
that they have the capability for
democracy so is there something in the
religious tradition if it is I'm not
aware of it and is there anything in
their experience and if there is i'm not
aware of it well there's certainly
nothing in their historical experience
that would accord with our western
developed notion of democracy proponents
of this islamic democracy particularly
the clerical reform reformers such as
mr. Khedive are or another cleric we
haven't mentioned the very important
figure Ayatollah Montazeri will tell you
that there are elements of sort of
democratic tradition within Shia Islam
unlike Sunni Islam which I'm sure you
know is the minority and majority faith
in the in the Muslim world she had Islam
allows her a very high degree of
Independence for for individual cleric
senior clerics and to achieve this level
of Independence you have to not only be
learned and to write treatises and to
amass followers but you also have to
have the acclamation of the people and
of your peers and so multis re and by
extension his student Kathy VAR would
argue that that is a form of democracy
because these people develop a true
following they're not foisted upon the
people that perhaps Geneva doctor and I
think too that yeah I mean this is the
the relationship that the clerks have
with the state is really at the heart of
the distinction between Sunni and Shia
Islam this in the Sunni tradition in
Egypt as an example the the shakes that
were part of the official orthodoxy at
eleazar which is the institution for
SUNY Learning they were for centuries
basically a rubber stamp for the
government I mean even in recent
wars between Arabs and Israelis they
were used by President Sadat as a rubber
stamp on the system that has changed
though with the Islamic revival but this
differs of course in Shia Islam where
the the clerics have been traditionally
independent of the state and Phillips I
don't know if Joanne will let me but I
have two questions that if not you can
disregard it but one there is a very
large Iranian despite a diaspora
particularly in Los Angeles which has
several millions of the men then they
dispersed around the country I don't
know about other countries in the world
but I know here is there a relationship
are they in any way affecting or trying
to affect change working with the
Reformers that's my first question the
second question is that as I understand
it not only the Guardian Council but
they control the judiciary the military
and the police so how in the world is it
ever possible to have a reform movement
as long as those three branches of
government are totally controlled by the
clerics is there any possibility the
military belling or the police rebelling
or the Constitution we haven't heard so
much from the Diaspora and political
terms until very recently I think
largely with the coming of the Bush
administration and there and in the post
9-11 interest in sudden interest in
foreign policy Middle East policy in
particular there are elements of the
Diaspora particularly in Los Angeles as
you mentioned who feel that maybe now is
the time to begin to mount a challenge
to the clerical regime the Shah of Iran
or Pretender to the show wherever his
formal title is is been on radio
television and in the newspapers and has
been trying to mobilize we would argue
very very strongly that that does not
have resonance back home now that may
not prevent him from becoming a player
in international politics or it may not
prevent him from having access to the
White House but we would argue very
strenuously that he has no real backing
back home and that well Iranians are
generally unhappy in the current state
of affairs they are not looking for a
monarchist solution and we would also
argue they're not really looking for a
secularist solution either it's a it's a
very important question but very
complicated one you've identified the
problem obviously that it's the
Constitution as long as you have a
constitution which doesn't give power to
elected officials but gives power to
clerics then you're not going to have
democracy obviously the problem though
is that the Constitution and this gets
back to the thesis of our book the
Constitution was written on the basis of
religion because when Ayatollah Khomeini
inherited or developed the Islamic
Republic this was the first time in the
whole history of Shia Islam that clerics
had to sit down and create a framework
on how to run an Islamic state because
don't forget before that for centuries
they were outside the state and so this
is really the problem two decades on
that they're still trying to resolve and
yes they will have to go back and
basically rewrite the Constitution if
there's going to be any sort of
pluralistic system because as you've
explained it doesn't allow for that it
doesn't allow for any sort of democracy
now all Dane there are two factors
direct and then directors of variables
one dealing with the was a population he
was a democracy that is the minority
elements are they in any way factored in
such as the courts such as the Afghans
such as the historic peoples that were
at one time part of the Soviet Union and
then you mentioned students and your
business reference was to students
University students the population of
the people in the ron is now i think the
the highest was the percentage are under
a 30 of age were 30 years of age so they
were born after the booth war with
Iraq so therefore how do we factor that
them in and also what's puzzles me not
puzzles me but I'm curious is you as a
woman dealing with clerics and knowing
what I think I know about the Quran and
so on do you feel that what they told
you and so on was shall we say authentic
was it whitewash was it something that
they just wanted to get rid of you how
did you feel in your assessment and
dealings with them as a woman I presume
that you speak Farsi am I correct
alright and I also was by your English
accent that you were born in the United
States or an english-speaking country so
therefore were there was were those
obstacles thank you you talked about the
ethnic strife in the beginning it was
very difficult for the clerics to answer
serious questions from an American woman
one thing I did to sort of help my case
is I wore a door which is the black
shroud that people wear now this is not
required and most Western women
particularly journalists in Iran they
wear just a headscarf and an overcoat
and often it's a very flowery loose
headscarf but I did this in a very
deliberate way to send a message that I
was making concession to their Islamic
culture and and to try to send them a
message that you know that I I was
willing to sort of make this compromise
if they were willing to take me
seriously it took some time but after a
while they did take me seriously once I
presented the questions and in fact the
reason that Jonathan and I were able to
interview Ayatollah Montazeri this this
the successor to home a knee who's now
under house arrest he had never agreed
to an interview with a Western
journalist but we faxed him the
questions and they were all about
theology so a month later he sent back
an eight thousand word answer he had
never agreed to an interview before
because people asked him what he ate for
breakfast and what life was like under
house arrest
but when we asked him about the
intricacies of Shiite Islam he felt that
that was worth this time to answer so it
did take some work but over time you
know we established some representation
as people who were trying to understand
something deeper than red lipstick and
headscarves so i'll try address your
very good question about the
demographics yes you put your finger on
it the vast majority of Iranians are
under 30 have no real memory of any of
these events the revolution home a knee
possibly only some sort of nightmarish
memory of the bombs over Tehran or other
the fares associated with the war with
Iraq this is a very big factor in the
way things play out over time and
certainly you here and among Western
analysts that this is the factor but
what we found consistently and we always
pose this question to young people and
two clerics who work with young people
and to teachers and to anyone what we
felt that could give us some insight we
really came away completely convinced
and remain convinced that what the
Iranians want today in Iran the Iranians
in Iran I should say is a resistant that
respects their culture and their
religion now do they want this Islamic
system I think the majority would say
decisively no but they want a system
that works within their culture and
respects their values they don't want
they may like Titanic which was a big
hit when we were living there on the
black market they may like Michael
Jordan but they don't want to import
wholesale American values they want to
pick and choose as do many societies
an intelligence service has been
extremely aggressive both
internationally and domestically have
you seen any kind of dissipation of that
aggression or have you seen it been just
as strong both in terms of its control
of the population and its aggressiveness
in the Middle East particularly to be
frank we didn't really study too much
and it's as you can imagine extremely
complex matter probably best studied
from outside or certainly safer to study
I'm outside Iran we had limited exposure
to the sort of sharp end of the stick if
you will from the intelligence service
we were the targets of i would say
limited and rather soft harassment
nothing really you know they would come
into our office and move some of the
furniture around so that we knew that
they'd been there and things like that
but and our translators were
interrogated and we assumed that people
that we dealt with were followed but to
answer your question it comes down to
the division of power and in fact as a
previous question elucidated hata me is
probably arguably the least powerful
exactly elected executive in the world I
mean the office of President in Iran
does not have any of the functions that
everyone in this room I think to a man a
woman would would list as a natural
prerogative of an elected president
cannot declare war and peace it's not
command the Armed Forces can't really
control the police doesn't have final
say on foreign policy so he's kind of
left with the Ministry of Culture which
is in fact one of the reasons that I
didn't mention this in my talk that
newspapers became such a prominent
vehicle for the attempted reform because
in a way it was the only playground they
really could play in to try to answer
your question more specifically there is
no evidence that the we could find that
I mean many of the personalities in the
intelligence remain the same as an
expert I'm sure you know that there was
in fact the very feared head of
intelligence a cleric named dorina Jaffa
body was brought down by a government
scandal allegedly for participating or
at least abetting the murder of seculars
intellectuals and he was brought down by
the Free Press and in fact probably the
greatest success of the hot to me free
press was actually holding extremely
powerful fish
to account so yes there has been some
change but as far as we can tell from
our very limited vantage point I
couldn't really say that they've they've
cut back hot to me may not be in the
loop he may be I'm not really qualified
to say how does the clerical
establishment in Iran interact with the
foreign businesses there and has this
interaction resulted in any relaxation
of things like the prescriptions against
interest for example well as you implied
in your question there are extensive
length I'm sure everyone in this room is
aware that in many ways Islam is a very
sort of business friendly religion it's
a mercantile religion Muhammad his first
wife was a merchant um clerics in
business Rafsanjani in particular the
former president is renowned for
allegedly amassing an enormous amount of
wealth both personally and through his
family in connections to concessions for
private foreign businesses car factories
soda bottling plants etc it's that are
just Ashley o nuts of course um so yeah
the ties are quite extensive and they
come from the fact that right after the
Revolution they nationalized a huge
chunk of the property that was
controlled by the Shah and his inner
circle hotels controlled by big western
chains in fact it's quite amusing when
you ask at irani for it how do you get
to the Lal a hotel they don't know but
if you say oh that's the intercon twenty
years ago they all know where it is the
same is true of some of the other
sheraton I can't quite remember which
one is which anymore but if you need to
know hotel you don't use the current
name use the old name so there's a long
tradition of there was a big as you know
American business presence there and
they inherited a great deal of wealth
and business connections and of course
the bazaar is the traditional merchant
class in Iran very very big supporters
of home a knee when he was in exile and
very very big supporters of the
revolution and would arguably have a lot
to lose if the system opened up further
and
that is a source of that is an obstacle
I should say to the reform project
because a lot of the resources are
focused in very concentrated hands held
by people who benefit from the status
quo in terms of allowing business do we
haven't really talked about it but we're
also very insistent among all the other
things we insist on that not seeing the
clerics as monolithic and in fact hot to
me comes from a clerical association
that you can only really describe his
leftist they have a strong some of his
closest allies would probably support a
sort of return to Soviet central
planning if they could in the economy so
one of the fascinating things about Iran
and one reason we were interested on
every single day we woke up to find out
what we could discover was is this there
is no simple spectrum of left right
center social values economic policies
religious values they all intermingle a
very complex ways and it very difficult
to differentiate one from another until
you sort of going in and discuss these
things for many many hours take one more
question Larry bridge well what is your
forecast of the governance structure of
Iran ten years from today I'm gonna
leave that one to my wife certainly
we're going it's going to be far more
pluralistic I hate to use the D word but
then it is today um it it's also a
matter of demographics I think as
someone pointed out because now fifty
percent of the population is under 35 so
of course the people that are that are
in their 20s now they're going to be the
leaders in 10 or 20 years from now and
that certainly will change the political
dynamic what's going to happen to the
clerics is an open question the clerks
are obviously not going to disappear but
whether their role will move from
running the state to some sort of
advisory function within the state is
probably you know what they'll sort out
in the next 10 to 20 years and of course
if young people have their way the
future leaders of Iran the clerics will
probably have more of an advisory role
in the state
rather than a primary role so I think
that it's safe to say that the clerics
role will diminish but I don't think
that it will vanish from the scene it
also depends of course about what
happens in the Islamic role in general
if as we have seen Islamic movements
gain more power this indirectly is going
to give the clerics more power in their
in their insistence on running the state
so there are a lot of you know forces at
play not only in Iran but in the region
I just like to add and this may be of
interest to to the audience this
gentleman we've mentioned several times
I told a montessori the very long and
complex history and I won't go into that
now but he has written he did write in
eight thousand weren't treated as a
response to our questions it has been
translated into English and it's
available on our website and I would
tell you that is ww answering only to
god.com you also find stories about how
we were expelled from Iran and some
other stories that you might find
interesting very very thorough way some
of the the whole issues about the future
of Iran what can we can expect from the
client I think that's a roadmap that
people should use and take seriously it
may not be the direction but it's
certainly one direction under
consideration Thank You Jonathan genève
I want to thank you both for your
tenacity and perseverance and bringing
this struggle of the islam vs islam to
us this afternoon thank you thank you
genève Abdul and Jonathan lions are
co-authors of answering only to God
faith in freedom in 21st century Iran
it's published by Henry Halton company
on the web at Henry Holt calm